So you're all set to do your audition for the You Generation.
But practice makes perfect,...
...so you're gonna want to rehearse it beforehand with your friends over Skype.
Mine are here.
Hello.
Hi, Matt.
Now, it's important to think about some of the technical issues that you may face.
For example, you'll want to frame your shots nicely so that you look good.
You want to make sure that you're heard,...
...so your sound is working or whatever device you're recording on.
And think about lighting as well because obviously, it's your talent that counts,...
...but we want to give it the best possible opportunity to shine.
For example, at the moment, this is pretty good.
But this, not so good.
Also, a little bit scary; can we turn the light back on, please?